في اخبارنا الاخرى اكد بيان مشترك صدر عن
الحوار الاستراتيجي الثاني بين دوله قطر
وفرنسا على متانه العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين وقالت الدائره الاعلام والاتصال
بوزاره الخارجيه القطريه ان البلدين اكد
عزمهما على تعزيز التعاون في المجالات
الاهتمام في مجالات الاهتمام المشترك
وتحديد مشاريع مشتركه للدفع بالتعاون
الاستراتيجي بينهما وحسب البيان المشترك
اكد الجانبان التزامهما بنظام دولي يستند
الى القانون فضلا عن تعزيز السلام
والاستقرار والازدهار في الشرق الاوسط
ومواصله التعاون الوثيق فيما يتعلق
بالازمات الاقليميه والعالميه واستعرض
الجانبان حسب البيان المسائل الاقليميه
والدوليه والدفاع والامن والتجاره وقضايا
اخرى
ووقعت دوله قطر وفرنسا خطاب نوايا بشان
التعاون والشراكه في مجال التنميه الدوليه